mark hamilton you had the granddaddy you
had i mean one of the biggest
secrets of cinema history right uh the
darth vader
[Laughter]
kids are just at episode two what
so how long did you have to keep that
secret well the contrast was
when we did star wars nobody cared you
know i
read it and i i gave it to my friend to
read i said that this is the goofiest
thing i've ever read
and then he called he said you're right
it is goofy uh
can i give it to meredith i said sure i
passed it all around
nobody cared by the second film that's
when
their scrutiny became more intense and
there was a wonderful
substitute revelation
in that scene and the way we filmed it
vader said
you don't know the truth obi-wan killed
your father
and the idea of alec guinness being the
real villain i thought wow what a
spectacular
twist and it's just as you see in the
film no search your feelings you know
it's true
wallop the hand goes off
but so vividly
the director irvine kirschner uh took me
aside he came to my dressing room
actually and he said
i'm going to tell you something i know
it george lucas knows it and when i tell
you
you'll know it but if it leaks we'll
know it was you
so i said what what and he handed me the
piece of paper that said
i am your father. i was shocked i said
is that is that true he said well
you search your feelings and we're going
to play it like that
so oh my gosh dad vader
and then i was paranoid because i
thought you know it was way before
social media
and all of that but i had to keep the
secret for about a year and a half
i didn't tell carrie i didn't tell well
you know telephone telegraph tell it
carrie
she had no vault whatsoever in fact
harris and i would test her if you
really wanted to get something out fast
you ask carrie to keep it in your
confidence
so at the screening when that happened
harrison turned to me and said hey kid
he didn't tell me that
i apologize for the f-bomb i only used
it for historical accuracy
yeah i mean i was so thrilled because i
mean i don't like
having the the burden of that i talk in
my sleep you know it could be
really dangerous does harrison like your
impression on him
no actually he once said to me hey i
don't sound anything like that
it's very accurate is shrouded in in
secrecy the whole thing we're not
allowed to know anything so
daisy how long did you have to keep the
secret of actually being in it that
you've got the part
three months no three months you have to
tell someone in three months
did you not know that oh i told them
when i got cast i told the taxi driver
you didn't tell anyone i i released it
the other day i did tell the taxi driver
i can't lie to you i did
your family didn't know no my family
didn't know the taxi driver did
i got in the taxi and i was just like
mate i've just been cast in star wars he
was just like
all right mate
so who did you tell first daisy i told
my sister and my mum when i came in and
then i told my dad and then
he was kind of sleeping he went jesus
christ and then
and then the next day he was like i
think your mum told me something and i
was like no no i told you that
and then you went oh i was always more
of a trek fan
that's a bad father he's great he's back
today yeah how was your family when you
heard of john
um they had no clue what star wars was
but they were great that i got a job
and carrie the secrecy thing how have
you managed to keep
i mean did they give you a script did
they give you a script
they gave me a script for about three
hours and waited on you know out
by the gate and uh so it was a lot of
pressure
to i just looked for my bits no idea
what context it was in nothing
and i still don't know
so uh you know i uh i i don't know it
was awful but i told him
no no i i and i kept the secret so she's
so rubbish
she told me because i knew i'd do the
show one day and
it would help me
yes have you seen the film yes but
before that
a year ago she told me yeah everything
everything
oh my gosh
[Laughter]
i can't believe it i love all the people
to trust with the secret i'm not the one
i thought you were luke yeah i know i
was very sure you developed you as a
person no but here's the thing
so he doesn't just wonder
is he happy to stay there overexposed
and he's tired
okay so he'll be fine should we ignore
him absolutely
act like nothing happened he's having a
whale of a time
his back hurts a little bit
he needs him he is doing yoga
i don't believe his schedule well listen
there's an awful lot of people in the
audience who love you
and so all right calm down
so i'm just going to give an opportunity
for some of them to say i love you so
uh so who where oh look at her blue hand
right up there
oh yeah you already did it can you uh
okay what's your name anna
anna and stand up where are you from
anna uh sorry
sorry i love harrison that's the point
now wait a minute
we get into that okay so there he is
he's he's he's not going any nearer
but okay look him in the eyes and tell
him
oh wait for the wait for the music for
the movie look at the
eyes i love you
[Applause]
[Music]
i know
[Applause]
can someone else have a go do you mind
yeah sure
yeah you're there you're there what's
that what's your name
yoka what yoka from belgium
yoker yokan yoko yo
yo leave her alone
so you're fr do you live here now no i
don't so you're just here from belgium
on holiday
i came for this yes to see mr ford yes
okay so here we go here we go so
i love you
thank you
your mother loves you because you're her
daughter yeah but she
is actually a sort of a fan as well you
know it's not
she's not quite that it's um
she is oh goodness right so my
uh uh one day my mom came to set on
the star wars set uh and i was getting
this thing called cyber scand
which is where you stand in this kind of
loads of cameras and they kind of take
your form and put you into a computer
and make a toy or a
some sort of merchandise or your face on
a cushion
yeah um and so i go off and do this and
i come back and mum's like i've made a
great friend and i'm like brilliant it's
lovely
excellent and she's like the merchandise
you know director of all of star wars or
something and i'm like wow
very impressive and then before i know
it what comes in the post
is loads of cushions
my face on it so my own mum i guess
she gets to see it a fair amount you
know but apparently it's not enough so
i was kind of blown away how much
merchandise there is
yes and it's just the beginning it was
like the pre-merchandise not even the
real stuff is out yet
and my mom has all of it and doesn't
know about the doll yet so
this is so weird i don't know is this in
your flat or her house goodness
okay so basically she'll be really funny
if i came home and it was everywhere in
my room
okay so this is this is this is amelia's
actual bedroom
[Applause]
oh and then oh my goodness we found the
photo but it's not like that now
there is another reason why i'm saying
the first date back to that
yeah come on in
[Laughter]
this little thing once i don't have a cv
i just have a bedroom
daisy you get to use your lovely english
voice i do throughout
i do john not so much no
i have an american accent in there do it
he's so good no it's incredible your
accent is so good
oh thank you i mean i tried it in the
british but it didn't work out i'm a
stone trooper i'm gonna have a say yeah
did you do it on on stream uh yes
yes um and jj was just like uh john i i
don't think it's right
it's not so let's go with american but
what if you hadn't been able to do
america
then i would have been pissed
[Laughter]
because carrie way back in the beginning
19 was it 76
76 76 when you're on set your first day
on set you had a similar thing with an
accent
but mine was an accident accent
i had been it's viral i've been going to
school here
it's the central school of speech and
drama oh yes and we've been taught to
sort of
say what did you do to try to take it a
minute or two to two thing distinctly
hard to say but a harder thing to do
and so uh well all right
isn't it beautiful and you can see it in
all my work
all the levels and the layers so um
i went in it was like governor talking i
thought i recognized your foul stench
when i arrived on board now i did it
conversationally and george came to me
the only time i really got direction
from george was the first day he said
you are really upset you're
just about to have your planet blown up
and
you know such like and when i get upset
i become british
you're better at conflict than we are
clearly
and so i just so try to governor talking
i thought i recognized your foul stench
when i arrived on board
and where there are nerd fans
there are nerd tattoos and i believe
you've had your first
nerd tattoo yes yes i came across
um a uh a a a
a male um don't say it
listen who has had
the character of jinn tattooed onto his
um it's you he's had you tattooed well
yes i guess me and me as jen tattooed
onto his calf
oh i'm really worried for a second
[Laughter]
here you are here you are on a cough
oh my goodness oh man oh it's he's
there's his ankles
so they're amazing it's actually kind of
an oddly good lightness for a tattoo
yeah i'm just worried about what happens
when the hair grows back
i'm going to be a bearded lady it's
planet of the apes now
[Laughter]
one of the things we saw in in the clip
there effin and captain phasma you get
into it
you have a big a big fight and you've
been saying how
i guess it's ying and yang you're in the
the outfit
yeah which must make it harder yes not
ideal
not ideal to even move really in the
outfit let alone fight john but if
if you see what she was doing and and
the training it was
she was ferocious i was like can she
actually see
every time i was swinging at her i was
just doing
there was a there's a moment of contact
and the power
with which john uh met me with i will
never forget that was like
me like trying to save my own life
now i would say and i don't know if i
was a betting man
in that fight i would put money on
gwendolyn
because you do have the advantage well
we kind of talked about this i've got a
higher center of gravity so that's not
an
advantage i've got a contract on my side
[Applause]
so this is the start of the match sorry
about it no it only works if you stand
you've got
you don't know what i'm just warming up
my knees because
don't do tippy toes again
[Laughter]
okay here we go here we go
[Applause]
but your boys went to see uh the
premiere yeah they did they were there
last night
yeah they loved it they they um my
oldest obviously is 16 so
he was allowed out that late but romeo
normally
he's uh not um so last night he went
with his big brother and he had the
the honor and the thrill of watching it
and um i mean they both came back and
was raving about it and said it was
really incredible so
he had a good time you know what would
make your kids really jealous what's
that
is if you just pose with a lightsaber
with finn
that would actually make him very gentle
do it do it i got one i got one in
manchester united red
where is it no i really do i really do
where's the blue one again okay there's
the blue one
and actually now here's the thing
because you're in is it you're in the
new king arthur film
i am just a small part yeah have you
done some sword training
i have done something yeah well we're
looking for some oh look at him look at
this
okay you get that to work
i'm moving well yeah yeah can we not
kill
can we not kill kylie that's all i ask
now there's a so basically to turn this
on you push
you push that thing that one up okay
that there we go
you've got david beckham you've gone off
you have met your match
i just wanted to meet you mate
so this week you had the big london
premiere yes
and you were all there yeah and you all
got to meet royalty
yeah i said after you know
your royal highness and doing all that i
said can you settle this for me
my mother was queen amidala my father
was
lord vader my sister is
princess leia doesn't that make me
royalty
i was hoping you know that they would
agree william
said well absolutely i think that should
make you
i think i need more information
but here's the thing so so they're in
the movie uh are you
are you allowed to tell us which
stormtroopers they are you kind of have
to compare with body type
and try and figure it out i mean i only
had one question for harry when i met
him was whether he was going to have
nigerian catering at the wedding
i hadn't met them before and i also
hadn't realized my dress was slightly
sheer so i was
almost naked when i met rob
were they very good with eyes they
really kept the gaze up
and the party was in their house kids
need to palace yeah yeah
is that their house i don't know i don't
know if that's the way they live exactly
though because they talk about the
cottage i'm like is it a cottage
you know that but we know it's not true
yeah
so is there a function room how does it
work well you did walk sort of past like
a mess where people
it's like a canteen and i thought oh is
that where we're going but they had a
lovely thing upstairs it was like a red
throne thing
throne room place with the with the
right i wanted to pose the photographs
on there and was dragged away by yeah
yeah
yeah i was trying yeah
i had to resist the urge to nick an
ashtray as a souvenir
yeah i think they leave things out for
people to steal yeah
and now so it's a big premiere and the
boyega clan were out in force absolutely
uh you bagged extra tickets
oh now so this is your nephew yes
little jj no he's not called tragedy
after jj abrams
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no i just thought it
might have been a naughty name
yeah he's named after jar jar
[Applause]
[Music]
did you bring everyone to kensington
palace or was that was that oh yeah no
everyone everyone came down to the
palaces
yeah but as soon as 30 minutes saying my
dad was like where is the proper food
[Laughter]
even if you weren't in these films you
would be at that premiere
you are like a proper star wars i have
been a star wars fan since i was six
years old
yeah and i've really done my best to
keep away from you
mark not to bother and harass you and
how amazing that you then you were in
the star wars thing but also game of
thrones
so like i need to have
like when those people at premiere see
you gaming toads and stores they must
have like a
nerdgasm i think that's what it's called
yeah
and only occasionally there's an
omission
but you did rock up to work i mean that
that you that is you
yeah yeah they they spent a lot of money
removing me from the film
but yeah i was in a green suit
underneath it all and it was half a
practical suit in half
there you were yeah there i am so you
are sort of there i mean
it was over there yes yes
yes yes i mean no one had a clue who i
was at the wrap party because i was like
hey guys
oh
and that what is the story that at the
at the audition you weren't a star wars
aficionado no no i haven't uh
thanks for bringing this up uh
so you hadn't seen any of them and yet
you rock up for the audition
and rock up the audition and could you
put that on the thing because my
course safety first
the story time so i
uh yeah so i was i was going to the
audition and i thought i'm just gonna
this character was amazing she's a
revolutionary she's really cool and the
dialogue was amazing
and but it kind of said just in one of
the in the stage directions droid and so
i was like
droid freud what's the droid and then i
googled droid and then nothing much
really came up with it just pictures
there wasn't explicitly it was a robot
yeah it wasn't a taxi on the ladies
audition i was like really
shouldn't know what a droid is and i was
asking my taxi driver he was like i
don't know what a droid is and he called
his family
like who wants to drive and the more i
didn't know the more panicky i got and
then i got to the audition
and i was like i'm just going to play it
like a human because the chances are
it's a human because most of the times
when you audition it's for humans
so i went in as a human and i did the
audition they were like
the guys were like oh that's really
great thank you could you um
try it a bit more droidy what sort of
drawing
kind of vibe do you want and luckily one
of the directors went like this honestly
i saw his hand he was like a bit more
like
robots
i know what they were they decided they
didn't need it to be
droidy at all in the end i think it
might have worked in my favor that way
are you a good study the last time you
were you did me and you were very good
you did my laugh
very well that wasn't good yeah
it's do you do lots of people are you
one of those actors
no yes a few yeah but i mean i think i
think i think a lot of us
yeah don't we i mean it's either music
or it's or it's it's
it's voices or tones of voices i mean
you know i used to muck around with
dictaphones at school for ages and just
you know do interpretations on
impersonations of people and
create characters and it's just sort of
having an ear it's part of what we do i
guess
i mean even if it's not a real person
just to imitate or have empathy with
a state or a human being of any general
you were doing chewbacca during the clip
was i in time with the chewbacca thing
just natural nature that's one of my
favorites
see back at moments it's just that
i mean can i take you back
you look shocked to be back
is the thing about your your lightsaber
being a different color is that story
true that you
the purple lightsaber yeah uh yeah um
you know when i first got that job i
didn't know what i was gonna do
when i said i wanted to be in star wars
george invited me over the ranch i got
over and told him look
i just want to be in the movie i'll be a
storm trooper you can put me in one of
those white suits
let me run across the screen nobody
needs to know that but me
and i'll be happy he's like no we'll
figure out something so i got over here
and he made me a jedi um you know
um and i was pleased i did some seeds
with yoda and i did some
scenes and liam and everything was great
and then i came back the next year
last week okay he didn't kill me off
and there's this big we had this big
arena fight scene with all these jedi in
there fighting whatever
and i was like well i want to be
able to find myself in this big old
scene so i said to george you think
maybe i can get a purple lightsaber
lightsabers are green or lightsabers are
red yeah but i want a purple one
you know i'm like the second baddest
jedi in the universe
[Music]
let me think about it and when i came
back to do reshoot she said i'm gonna
show you something it's already causing
a storm online
and he had the purple lightsaber and i
was like yeah
so um i could find myself in that big
fight scene in the middle of that you
know
there's like 300 light sabers in there
there i am right there
a lot of these little tops like they're
real things they don't need
they may be the purple one now oh yeah
that's dope yeah they make this
one that's the expensive one no
there's nothing to do with it it just
what well there's a couple things you
can do with it and
one of them would be give it to me
that's probably in the office would be
you know can i just say someone in the
office
[Applause]
yeah look at that if my son had that
i would be decapitating he does no oh
i have the real one at home that has bad
right here
[Applause]
[Laughter]
this is amazing this gives you power
yeah you look good with it i feel good
don't touch that part
oh you don't touch that no
whoa
[Applause]
it just went off in your hands
[Music]
is it true or not that you you kept a
lightsaber
i officially don't own a lightsaber
props guy gave me one no i didn't
you have to know what you're doing with
these you see you do though
is that the which one would you like
which one looks like yours um the one in
the middle is i think uh the the one i
use
that's that's alec guinness one oh
they're the chores yeah yeah oh my god
this these are really nice it's amazing
how do you turn them can you bang them
against each other will they break
oh no they won't but you make the sound
effects yourself
do you want to do you want one not at
all come on
there you go there go go go you get a
good sword oh look at that
what that's fantastic but can you make
the noises oh can i is it true that you
did
this thing i'm sure you could ask this a
thousand times
yeah like in rocket they did this at
rocky as well
where they had to you would make the
sound effect yourselves
so they had to go back and like sound
was a nightmare
because it was a bunch of people going
no it wasn't to begin with it was quite
difficult not to make the sound
yeah and also when it goes away because
it makes that nice
noise when it goes down oh yes have you
heard that in rocky the partly like the
in the first film particularly
it's just loads of sound effects of
sylvester still all good
okay let's look at the light let's have
the lights down let some lights down
because you have to you have to start
them up
oh okay so off off
how would you do that
yeah much down there
okay so when you put it on it has to
make this turn a noise
you're so good at it i did it i spent
months doing it
mine keeps going off though when i twirl
it i could ow
[Applause]
how much at the cost 150 quid each
if i are you going to kick it if i show
you something can you
get over do it over here hang on i'll
throw this here wait who's who you just
there you go actually i should be can
you collect can you throw a ball
chris i can't be like that i can't throw
it
on no you go you go you go you go okay
okay here we go
all right we're good let's baseball it
baseball it's
[Applause]
what are you going to do with them you
can have them if you want to well we
could sign them and give them to this
chat
you take yours
[Applause]
sit here like this or the rest of the
interview
like a snicker player